[Music]  heart failure patients needs mechanical  assistance to help the heart to pump  blood around the body current devices  that mechanically assist the heart take  blood from the heart and pump it through  foreign materials which can lead to  complications such as clotting and  stroke our device gives mechanical  assistance from the outside of the heart  without contacting the blood which  avoids the patient having to be on  lifetime medication  [Music]  [Music]  the way the actuators are oriented  recreates the squeezing and the twisting  motion of the heart and gives it extra  assistance to help pump the blood  [Music]